it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
jeene ko no scoped from the CBS
television news staff Larry lesser and
Winston burr depth our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Robert Caine representative from New
Jersey last month the president sent a
message to Congress it was about
increasing foreign trade both ways
imports and exports the president
proposed an extension and amplification
of the reciprocal trade act for three
years and in each one of these three
years he would reduce tariffs by five
percent now this is the first Republican
administration in memory that has called
for a reduction in tariffs and
representative Cain you're a veteran
Republican congressman and yet you've
introduced a bill that would implement
the president's proposals now isn't this
practically revolutionary for a
Republican no I don't think it's
revolutionary in the bills that we've
had for carrying on reciprocal trade I
think the majority of Republicans lately
have voted for them now i'm in favor of
more foreign trade i think that it's
very important with the position we find
ourselves in the world if we don't have
more foreign trade i don't think we're
ever going to get these foreign nations
or for next well what do you think would
be in the interest of the country sir to
reduce these tariffs because if these
nations are not able to sell us their
goods they can't buy our goods and
that's essential in order that we keep
full employment in this country well
representative Kane to get down to
dollars and cents
under the tariff bill if this bill is
passed and and implemented reasonably by
the president how substantial benefit
how great a benefit when it afford to
European industry that is seeking an
American market not very great but it's
a step in the right direction and it
will encourage them to feel that this
country isn't going to set up I on wall
or a stone wall and try to prevent any
of their goods coming into this country
we represent only a small step and in
this step we will are going to try to
protect the interests of the American
producers and not try to put anybody out
of business representative Cain if the
bill will not give too great a benefit
to for producers nevertheless do you
think you can get all Republicans in
Congress to back your proposal no I
don't think so i think that there's a
great deal of opposition to any step in
the direction of freer trade in fact
they've been the bills introduced and is
a good deal of feeling that perhaps we
ought to raise tariffs rather than roll
well certainly you of that could you
give a realistic answer to this question
and that is how far do you expect your
tariff proposals to get this year at the
session not too far this year I think
what probably will happen will be a
straight extension of the reciprocal
trade act for one year that's my guess
you think it's possible that the your
bill would just be set on and committee
by representative read well I think that
it being administration proposal we will
have probably have some hearings but I
do not think that it's very probable
that the bill will be reported out in
the form that I've introduced it though
I wish it would be well speaking of
administration proposals as a prominent
member of the House Ways and Means
Committee you have this proposal now for
tax revision and the Democrats are
against that as i understand it
especially in the case of the
lowering of taxes on dividends they
would propose a reduction in the or
upping in the tax exemption now witness
actually benefit more consumers than
those who have stock investments from
which they get dividend sir why yes
consumers purchasing power would be
bettered by a increase in exemptions but
you've got to remember that we already
have put a tremendous a lot of money in
consumers hands by the other tax
reduction bills which have been passed
first place the the ten percent cut in
in taxes of income taxes generally then
there was the 1 billion dollar excise
tax reduction which went into effect on
April first and then in this very tax
revision bill there is about 750 million
dollars of benefits to consume it in
this bill there is only approximately
600 million dollars which is business
aid and that is only ten percent of the
entire tax reduction program and all the
hollering all the shouting that the
opponent's been making has been about
this ten percent of business a well sir
out of all the tax relief that is
provided under the administration's tax
program for this year how much would you
say can fairly be said to be tax relief
for the individual consumer about 4
billion 500 million it goes to the
consumer and then we have the business
we have in the tax revision bill
approximately 600 a million and then
there was the repeal of the excess
profits tax which was approved by both
Democrats and Republicans alike for the
benefit of business of course
representer can you talk in round
figures but the Democrats are proposing
that the exemption be raised by at least
one hundred dollars now is not going to
be pretty hard to come by
when you're talking him these round
figures about helping corporations well
of course the one hundred dollars
reduction in exemption would cost the
Treasury two billion four hundred
million dollars you add that to the
deficit that we already had of probably
around five billion dollars and you have
7 billion 400 million dollar deficit
which is pretty hard to handle and to me
it's not quite honorable to for us and I
think it's cowardly to pass on to future
generations to our children and
grandchildren the result of our Follies
I think we oughta get right to work and
try to come as close as we possibly can
to balancing the budget well sir senator
George is proposing the individual
exemptions be raised by two hundred
dollars that would be four billion eight
hundred million dollars this year yes
and next year he proposed that it would
be four hundred dollars which would be
almost ten billion dollars and to me is
a completely irresponsible proposed well
sir with Senator George making that
proposal for a two-hundred-dollar rise
in the individual exemption it's
conceivable that the Senate may approve
a 100-dollar rise in the exemption and
then what kind of a fight would ensue on
the on the floor of the house if well
it's into the bill Avery go to
conference of course and i think the
house conferees would turn it down now
in the when the bill came to the house
before the democrats made that proposal
and in that proposal was the hundred
dollar reduction and that was beaten by
210 to 204 it was a close call I wish we
could raise the exemptions I wish we
could raise him to a thousand-dollar
fact I was the author in the tax bill in
1946 of the amendment which raised the
exemptions from five hundred dollars to
six hundred dollars but you just can't
do it with the front circumstance is but
the Democrats do charge that the your
proposals do give so many benefits to
corporations like in these rapid
write-offs now isn't it true that the
consumer is the person that buys these
goods and he doesn't have the money how
are we going to keep the economy on a
stable plan well of course the consumer
makes money if you he's employed and the
only way to get them it is employed is
to provide jobs if you don't have
successful employers you don't have any
employees you don't have any payroll you
don't have any jobs the employer must be
successful was the final question like
to ask you representative Cain how much
possibility do you think there is of the
president's proposals going through his
program going through at this session of
Congress he's made a great many
proposals now from taft-hartley revision
to taxes well I think that we'll have
more of the president's program adopted
than any president's program since World
War two now the tax program i think as
they all will be approved we have gone a
little further than he's asked by the
excise tax revision bill I think the
social security bill in which I'm very
much interested we'll go through very
closely to in the form to which it was
recommended taft-hartley is doubtful
and more things have been put in by the
committee's and what the president wants
and whether anything will be done I
don't know the appropriation bills have
gone through very much along the line of
what the president wants I think there's
a good chance that the president's
program for these and lawrence seaway
will at long last go through I think the
health and welfare program of the
president will probably go through
Hawaiian statehood went through the
house but it's been bogged up in the
Senate by the attachment to Alaska which
has practically no population and
therefore great many people are opposed
to that in other words you're pretty
optimistic about the president's program
I think so thank you very much
representative Kane we're pleased to
have you here tonight join the opinions
expressed on the lawn Jane crow no scope
for those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the launch in
chrono scope was Larry lesser and
Winston burr depth our distinguished
guest was the Honorable Robert Caine
representative from New Jersey